[Music]
hey wassup Samuel leaves here and on
this video I'm actually I'm going to
share with you some of the feedback that
I've had from my customers and students
on how I can be better and not just me
but on how our company a training
business can be better so I think it's
really important to take on feedback and
it's easy sometimes to think that a to
mix up the difference between a critic
and a hater so let me explain the
difference a critic is someone that
wants the best for you and will give you
constructive feedback based on
experience so they've become a customer
they've loved your product or they
haven't loved Dennis do you know what I
think I think it could be even better
this way that's what I'm talking about
today every single time I ever run a
training program or our company runs a
training program we always ask people
for feedback and of course the response
is overwhelmingly positive we have the
highest success rates than any other
property training company on the planet
I believe happy to be proved wrong but
it's just insane
however there's things we can improve on
so these were these were the common the
common things that came up quite quite a
few times and I'm going to go through
them now so the first one was be less
pushy with sales and stop growing too
big and making it all sound too easy Oh
interesting okay so there's the six more
the seven okay I'm gonna address every
single one of them make an online paid
version of the crash course okay I get I
got that all the time I think people get
frustrated because they love coming to
the crash course but people fly in from
all over the world if you've been to a
crash course you'll see that typically
we've got 17 countries represented when
I'm there anyway and it costs a lot of
money on flights and things like that so
they just want the information they're
happy to pay for it but I just want it
at home so okay
allow others to share the stage with you
Samuel and also share your platform okay
cool
I think again what this is is people
want to like me I've got in my belly
I've got a desire to teach people and
just speak
stage and share inspire and a lot of my
students that become successful have
that same desire and they're saying hey
Samuel you know let us let us speak give
us more of a platform okay cool
offer more affordable and accessible
training on legislation and compliance
okay have better and faster customer
service have the crash courses in a
variety of locations not just London and
Birmingham and the last one number seven
is fund more property deals for people
with no money okay because one of the
things that we do is we actually fund
people's deals on the Academy like a
bridging company almost but we don't do
that all the time
okay thank you let me address these and
also as I address these as well maybe
you're not a customer and it's not this
you might think this isn't too relevant
to you but I want you to just kind of
see how I take on feedback because we're
even even if you're not in business just
as a person you should always be open to
feedback so that's a critic a hater a
hater is someone that's trying to bring
you down that's the definition of a
hater this I don't think this is hey
this isn't hey there's people this is
people saying Samuel please do this
because it will make your business even
better or sunny what you're really good
but this and then just give him feedback
that's not that's not being a hater I
forgot all haters and that will be
really stupid of me
instead you all want to lean into this
and grow from it I hate to be someone
that's trying to bring you down so I
hate or be someone that says something
like you know just comment on the videos
I oh this is this is BS or it's it's
someone that's just trying to bring you
down usually because of there are the
jealousy the jealous that you're
succeeding and others try and bring you
down or they're just such negative
people some people are just attracted to
the negative light I like to surround
myself by positivity and I don't have
any time for haters whatsoever you're
gonna have haters for everyone hate
you've helped one hundred but you know I
don't I like to spend time generally
focusing on the positive but I thought
I'm address and
these things so let's do it okay so make
an online paid version of the crash
course I get this asked a lot I'm gonna
do it okay I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do
it next year in 2020 at some point so
you can get off my back and know that it
is coming however although I'm gonna do
it and I am going to charge for his ways
here I don't know how much it'll be I
might charge I don't know I don't know
people at the moment people are
travelling from all over the country and
and just on flights you know then what a
long-haul flight could be two or three
thousand pound and then hotels and
everything like that and then time away
from family so it's not gonna be cheap
okay because I want to meet people
because I believe that learning is
better when it's done in in the right
environment so if you want to do the
crash course and you want to do it
online I will make it but it probably is
gonna be a couple of thousand pounds so
and you have the choice you can either
come down physically but I will do it
it's gonna happen next offer more
affordable these are in no particular
order by the way offer more affordable
and accessible training on legislation
and compliance that's really interesting
okay okay firstly sometimes people want
more information on all the legislation
side of things and that's not their
problem they don't need to know about
the legislation because they do at some
point but not right now
my advice generally is to focus on the
money-making activities focus on most
people's problems if they haven't got a
deal and if they had idea they wouldn't
have an investment to sell it to in the
first place not that they're don't know
how to beget insurance like come on and
what people do is they spend so much
time learning about all the non
money-making things
what business card shall I have what
logo how do I set up a company you know
how do I save tax you don't need to save
tax because you're not making any money
you need a focus on the money make
activities however that's my opinion but
people do all the time say that they
want more affordable accessible training
on legislation compliance so we are
writing a book okay and this isn't me
personally brought in this I've got some
of my students and colleagues partners
who are going to write together a book
it's going to be a one-stop shop all
about compliance as a as a deal packager
doing rent to rents as a landlord as an
investor just all about compliance and
legislation and we're going to put it
out there and this is gonna be normal
normal like this isn't going to be
thousands it's not going to be hundreds
it's probably going to be like 10 or 20
pounds ok this book on compliance it's
coming and that's going to be coming by
the end of this year so then it's a
couple of months the book should be with
you ok that's our aim anyway if not I'd
be very early next year have better and
faster customer service okay yeah you
know what a customer service is
sometimes really good hopefully usually
really good but it has been the last few
months a little hit and miss I think the
reason for that has been that we have
grown really fast we've also moved
offices to London and there's there's
been teething problems like phone lines
and people changing email systems and
setup so but we do need that how are we
addressing that I mean I don't get super
involved with that department but I know
that we are taking on four new customer
service advisers in the next six weeks
so that's something that I know the team
are really aware of best better faster
customer service 100% our training is
the best in the world I also want to
have the best business in the world I
want our customer service to be best as
well so you know if it's taken a while
for your book to be sent to you I know
that was probably linked to this there
was there's been a lot of books and it
really does it really doesn't normally
when that happens because I spend so
much time and effort right in the book
and then publishing it and then telling
people about it and then when someone
orders it and it doesn't come straight
away and it takes time it's really quite
a percent for me as well so yeah bear
bear bear with us on that front if
you're someone who's taking a long time
for the book to
we're here we're here for you guys we
really are as a company but sometimes
the volume of orders that we get and the
and the change of office recently and
and growing in the business so we get in
there we're taking what we're doing what
we can you know which is the next six
weeks they can for new people on so I
think we are dealing with that and
thanks for your patience if you've had
to wait for an email back we've not a
confirmation or an email when you've
booked on the crash course or whatever
so totally get that and agree okay okay
what else we've got
crash courses in a variety of locations
not just London Birmingham it kind of
irks me when people say that because I
just think just travel man just go where
it is all I wanted to do some training
with Grant Cardone it's in Miami I
didn't think it's in Miami I just jumped
on a plane it's I just don't see what
the issue is at all and I think that if
you're gonna let a plane journey or a
long car journey stop you then you're
probably stoppable and if you stop well
you're not going to be successful anyway
however that's my opinion that being
said we are going to do crash courses in
2020 and we're going to branch out and
we're gonna come back to Manchester whoa
all the Manchester folks and we're also
planning on going to Ireland as well
doing one in Ireland and Scotland so
we'll see how that goes and there's
really a couple of other locations in
the UK which we are going to be do
intend to bring the crash course to in
2020 so we've listened we've heard I've
been fighting some of you guys for ages
on this I've been saying because the
thing is from my point of view whilst I
want you to be or whatever it takes
person I want you to just travel at the
same time I want to make it so easy for
people because I know that once you've
done the crash course I know you're
gonna have your eyes opened and you're
gonna walk out transformed and your life
will change so I want to make it really
accessible for as many people as
possible
and that's why we often run the crash
course for free as well which is
ridiculous because it costs us tens and
tens and tens of thousands of pounds
just to put on just to put on one event
with everything that's all considered so
I've heard you thank you all right fund
more property deal for people we've
known money this isn't criticism this is
more people just requesting it people
are always asking you know Sam
can you fund my Dell can you fund my
Dale listen I can only fund people's
deals that are in the property investors
Academy they're my students and even
less students I cannot fund every day
because I haven't got the money I think
what I what I'm gonna do on that one is
because I do fund a lot of deals I I've
probably put 3 million pounds of my own
money into other people's deals in the
last 7 months which is you know insane
really and it means that sometimes
people say to me Sonia you sell people
dreams you can't buy a house with no
money I don't sell people dreams I
facilitate people's dreams by giving
them the money to dip it and then I take
a profit share but but so many my
students are buying houses without using
any of their money because I'm funding
the deals but I can't do that for
everybody so what I'll say on that front
is let me just brand you the reason I've
got so much money in the first place is
because people know who I am
you know they say it's not what you know
it's who knows you sometimes so one of
the things I'm doing to make it easy for
my students to succeed is winners
Wednesday when you come on winners
Wednesday what happens is you have Hunt
and anyone that's been on winners month
they will tell you this if they have
time because they want to have time to
speak to you because they've been on
winners Wednesday because what happens
is you have hundreds of inboxes from
people saying can we kind of take you up
for a coffee can we talk I'm interested
in doing and don't mention with you
people queuing up and you cannot buy
that kind of marketing you cannot buy
that kind of branding you cannot buy
that kind of advertisement and it would
come with it would cost tens of
thousands of pounds so what I'm trying
to do is I'm trying to brand myself but
also brand my students because what that
means is number one it it what number
one is it makes me feel good because
more success students are almost like
mini celebrities and then they become
more successful and then I'm part of
that journey anyway but secondly is if
I'm branding my students it's going to
make them more successful more grateful
to me hopefully and it's going to mean
that they can they can raise more
finance so what I'm trying to say is
instead of asking me for my money which
I might be able to give you you better
off taking action getting some deals and
then trying to get on my YouTube channel
because even this video I'll probably
have thousands of views and this is
quite a detailed video so
like the winds winds the videos that
blow up so get on that and and what
you'll find is it will be very easy to
then sell deals to people and to raise
finance and to joint venture and
hopefully is a result with your success
and you being successful those hundreds
of people that message you you'll be
able to shout out myself
and that training programs so the reason
we don't really advertise that much is
because we just will I just rely on
organic content putting stuff on YouTube
and I rely on people sharing the word
and there's so many people out there
that are financially free if you sort of
myself and my company's training we just
rely on being so good that everyone
knows about it so I hope that answered
the the question of fun more deals it
was quite a detailed way of answering it
what else we've got allow others to
share my stage and platform again I'm
branding people I'm getting them to
share their story on youtube I think
what people really want them is they
want to speak on stage because I know
for me when I became financially free
and people wanted to stop like stop
talking about property and stuff when I
went on stage I just got such a kick out
of it and it's like my mission now I
have a fire in my belly I want to speak
on stage and I want to share and all
inspire people I like that's part my
mission I'm inspired when I'm inspiring
other people and I know people want to
want to be part of that as well I know
we've had people that are making 10
grand a month 20 grand a month even now
it's they're like Alastair the
Cunningham he was starting making he was
making 40,000 pounds a month in property
ok when he met me yeah yeah nobody from
property at all nothing he'd be in the
bad place and then these property
business took off and he wanted to start
speaking on stage so I trained him I
actually invented a training program and
I taught him how to speak on stage and
how to be a great speaker and if you
guys have seen me on stage I'm a pretty
good trainer and I taught him how to do
that and now he's training on stage so
it's fabulous and one of the things that
we're gonna be doing next year is maybe
do more of that because as we've got
more and more students wanting to learn
we need more and more teachers so if you
even watching this video if you're one
of my students and you're and you're
successful in property in you doing well
and speak to us about that we've created
a program which is called tell the world
that's what it's called tell the world
and it's all about how
to share your message check create your
story and and want to say create because
you might think I've not got a story are
my stories rubbish but actually if you
take the bits from it take certain bits
you can create something really powerful
and authentic as well so create a story
share that really well communicate that
well be a good trainer and opportunities
to get on stage so that program tell the
world is going to be something that
we're running we're going to be running
that next year so I'll put that out
there now if you want to be a trainer
you want to be a speaking you want to be
an influencer of course you've got to
earn the right first you've got to get
the story you've got to become
successful which we can help you do and
then for sure there will be
opportunities used to get on stage as
well so that's my answer to that
question okay
make an online version we've done that
one the last one be less pushy with
sales and stop growing too big and
making it all sound too easy I hate to
disappoint you guys if you don't like
sales and you don't like growth and us
grow like you're going to be really
disappointed because I'm gonna sell
harder and more next year than I've ever
sold before and the reason for that is
because I'm becoming more and more sold
on my training programs I'm becoming
more and more sold on my product on my
services on my company it's getting
better and better and as I'm becoming
more and more passionate about it it's
just gonna use out on me and if you
don't like that then I'm afraid
unfortunately I'm not changing that one
because because I think that if I didn't
sell my training programs I'd be
deserving the world and again stop
growing too big honestly I can't believe
people don't like that are you growing
too quickly listen man I'm growing too
slowly if you think I'm growing too
quickly and you don't like that it's
just gonna tick you off real bad because
I'm on my way to be a billionaire okay
right now my multi multi multi multi
multi-millionaire I'm on the way to be a
billionaire like I'm thinking too small
right now I'm running programs with a
thousand people I want to be running
programs you ten thousand people like I
think people that often said that we're
growing to bigger making it sound
it's often because the dayy become a
little bit of successful and then they
don't what anyone else to do it because
here's the bottom line the bottom line
is any idiot can make something simple
sound complicated to make themself look
intelligent but to take something
complex and make it sound simple that's
called being a good teacher because a
good trainer will make something sound
simple so you can do it because
complexity is actually the thief of
execution in other words if something
sounds complicated you just won't do it
so people make things sound complicated
because they don't want you to do it
guess what I want you to do it I want
people to be financially free and I
believe that I honestly believe that
there's enough money and resources on
this planet for every single human being
to be financially free like that is a
core belief in me and I'm gonna spread
that message to as many people as I can
and people when I was telling my
training programs guess what I do with
the money I don't spend the money I
don't see the money that people give me
for training programs I'm gonna set wage
the money that we get I just put it back
into hiring more videographers and
telling the world and training more
people and bucking more venues
I'm not going to slow down on the frame
so that's that that's I think every
single one of the others I think I've
been like yep fair point and enough but
but when it comes to people saying to me
can you sell less and can you stop
growing too big and can you stop making
it sound too easy no because there are
more and more people on training I'm
realizing that actually financial
freedom is easy yes it takes yes it's
hard at the same time it takes work but
it's simple it is simple as you guys
thank you so much for watching this
video if you if you're still watching
and you watch the whole video that means
you're an awesome human being because
it's been quite a long detailed video
listen please do just drop a like drop a
comment below really appreciate you and
under for totally working with me
closely and getting to me real soon god
bless
[Music]